hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel and today i'm going to
be reacting
to traffic by frito bang you'll notice i
just changed the name of my youtube
channel it was just pearly things before
now it's just pearly songs
this was just to match up with my tic
tac account so it'd be easier for you
guys
to find um before i start the video do
not forget to like and subscribe i'm
really trying to move out of my parents
house
it's been rough not gonna lie so
subscribe subscribe
subscribe and don't forget comment what
video i should do next and comment is my
reaction accurate did i get it
let me know now okay i'm gonna start the
video now
don't hold your excitement i'm
[Music]
okay we excited a cool car very cool car
to start
[Music]
that is not safe he why is he sitting on
the side
i take my chances in traffic i ride with
a ratchet
i don't really talk about action when
it's time that i'm flashing i be rapping
okay so the first thing he said was that
he takes his chances
with traffic so he doesn't mind
if there's a little bit of traffic on
the road like he'll
like he's okay with it second thing he
says that he raps but
murder is his passion this is a little
concerning to me
i don't know if he's like a serial
killer or what but like
murder should not be your number one
passion i would say
maybe get a hobby i i'm not gonna tell
you how to live your life
but if that's your passion please don't
live next door to me that's all i got to
say
i take my chances in traffic
[Music]
with that [ __ ] i can do magic i'm
really bout to action
i rather take my chances and try so he
said with that 40
i can do magic i think that's a type of
gun so i think he's referring to his
murdering
hobby
[Music]
so he said a couple things he's very
money motivated which is great
i love money hungry friends you know
i think it's great if you want to chase
after money
however he said some concerning things
he said if he met a gangster you know
like
that he would turn them scared
i mean that's fine whatever like
i guess like what are you scaring them
with your murder hobby like
i'm not sure this is a wholesome song
i'm going to continue
i'm really about to check my background
[Music]
i really see the [ __ ] face down hey
i already know how that drake song
we keep that pills to close but we ain't
never scared
keep them snakes fall they talk to the
fed play with one of mine
we feel a moment and if i see you as a
up then you
already dead okay so he's got a couple
things so
he i've learned when i was growing up
if something bad happened you went to
the police
like if i saw someone get murdered or if
i saw something bad happen
you go to the police but i'm learning
that snitches
get in trouble so he's letting you know
that like snakes
aka snitches or the opposition like
he doesn't like they're not cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again like he's really passionate about
traffic like i'll take my chances in
traffic i won't like i'm gonna google
maps it see what the traffic is for the
day
and really like see if i want to deal
with the traffic but
i think he's saying like he's not gonna
google maps anything
he's just gonna he'll take his chances
whatever happens happens
give a [ __ ] what you think bust a [ __ ]
brain trick
[ __ ] never stand down [ __ ] my mama
race the gangster
draco smith okay
so this is another theme that i've
noticed
they always want to say like that
they're not like
in the song he's saying like he's not
gonna back down
his mom raised a gangster
i thought a gangster was a bad thing
like my mom always said
that's scary no
no he's saying that like his mom
raised him to be someone that doesn't
back down
he's not scared of nothing i can see my
hitter better
be the one to pop something up why you
got your clocked up
hit the pawn shop and going soon as i
cops
okay so he mentioned going to a pawn
shop so i think he's selling something
and then he also mentioned like having a
lot of options i think he meant like
different
gun options because he mentioned a 40.
i don't know what that has to do with
the pawn shop but another question i
have is
what is the owner of the gas station
thinking like these two luxury cars
just pull up and then like you and your
friends are dancing and rapping at the
gas station
i just want to know like what what the
owner is thinking
does he like did they schedule this or
did they just like
show up questions i have
um
[Music]
they're very cool cars
[ __ ] got some smoke
[Music]
[Music]
so again he's really just saying like
the same type of themes here
you know he'll take his chances in
traffic um
his friends are kind of ratchet and
like he murders his passion um
so that that concludes the music video
my impression
of the song is like i liked the tone and
like i feel like i could dance to it
with my friends
okay i don't have that many friends but
the friends i do have
we would bump we would really bump
i swear we would shimmy we would shimmy
a little bit
so i liked that but i don't think
murder being your passion is like
that's not the best thing so i don't
know if i like the messaging but overall
i give this like a six out of ten it
probably if it wasn't for the lyrics i
would probably give it like an
eight honestly because the b was
it was nice so let me know in the
comments
did i get it right did i get it wrong
what would you change about my analysis
is there any terms that i didn't pick up
on it's always interesting to learn from
you guys
and comment what video should i do
next and don't forget subscribe
subscribe
subscribe i will talk to you guys later
bye